if you're visiting Hong Kong here are
some of the best bites to get your geek
eat now every geek has to eat and there
are so many choices first on our list is
Chicho fun a very popular street food
and it's very simple but delicious snack
it's rice rolls with a combination of
different sauces it's sweet Savory and
nutty all rolled into one now if you
spot a Cha-Cha thing then don't hesitate
because these local cafes are one of the
best spots to grab Hong Kong milk tea
and local comfort food and don't forget
to try the beef and egg sandwich while
it's hot it's so good and if you're a
fan of bean good then you have to head
down to the commonweal Bean cut factory
they still make soy products the
traditional way and they have all these
different types of soy products from soy
milk to Soy pudding and even soy ice
cream last but not least is sorrowful
rice it's a simple dish with roasted
fatty chasu and a fried egg over rice
that will have you coming back for more
there's plenty of things to see and do
here in Hong Kong so we recommend you to
check it out